6pm it's the latest edition of the
russian evening news from moscow
and that's what's ahead tonight and a
few of tomorrow's highlights as well
here on c-span
this is book notes c-span 60-minute
discussion with the authors of public
policy historical and political works
for the next hour you'll see behind the
titles and gain insight into the authors
as people and the experience experiences
which shaped their lives
this week our guest will be peter
mcdonald an officer in the british army
for over 30 years and author of the
recent book zap the victor in vietnam a
biography of general vo nguyen zapp
commander of the vietnamese army during
the indonesia and vietnam wars
[Music]
peter mcdonald author of zap on the
cover of your book it says the victor in
vietnam
why did you think the book of this
type at this point was uh
was going to be read
well um
i suppose the
i better started why i wrote the book
um
around the 30th anniversary of the fall
of d and b and foo
they have put a picture in the in the
newspaper
of this man zap
sitting
at the indian foo he was uh
i'm a bit of a helic wearing uniform
smiling at the camera
and it struck me how strange it was that
he was a man who had made such an
enormous impact
on the west
and nobody knew anything about it and
that it would be a great thing to be
able to write a book about him
so that was the seed that was sown um
in 1984.
i wrote the vietnamese embassy in london
and said that i would like to go to
vietnam to meet him and to write a book
about him
uh it then got
pretty
bureaucratic they had to refer to hanoi
and so on
the man i was dealing with was posted
back to hanoi
the new chap didn't know much about it
the whole thing faded away and i got
involved with another book
and i didn't really do anything about it
for quite a long time
but then in 1988
i began to think about it again
and in 1989 i approached the
vietnamese embassy again
there was a long
delay nothing much happened
i'd given it up really
and then this letter came saying it was
appropriate to go to hanoi
in december of that year because it was
the 45th anniversary of the founding of
the people's army
and that i could go and write about
zap and about the people's army
so that's really how it started
and then of course there was the
business of researching writing and so
on
so to answer your question directly i
mean there was no
feeling in my mind that now was the
right time to
produce the book it was events that
picked me up and took me along
and therefore
there was no particular
timing in the thing
i did hope though that um
the events would have faded a bit from
people's minds because of the trauma
that had been experienced both in france
and in
in america and i think that maybe the
book wouldn't have gone at all
uh early on
soon after those events
and i find now with a
passage of time that in fact in france
they still feel
tremendously
uptight about the indochina war
and perhaps and perhaps a bit
surprisingly a little less so in the
united states
is general zapp still alive yes oh yes
when did you last see him i saw him in
uh january of 1990. how much time did
you spend with him i spent several hours
with him
spread over
a number of interviews
what was he like
um
i really didn't know what to expect in
the sense that um
i had only seen the odd picture of him
i had read that he was not
very well physically
and
[Music]
also
i had read that
uh you know he was suffering from
parkinson's disease hodgkin's disease
and all this sort of thing
um
and he was quite an old man so i i
really didn't know what to expect as a
physical presence
the interviews were conducted in what
used to be the prime minister's
residence in in hanoi
and
i arrived there in good time and waited
for him to appear
he rolled up in a in a big black staff
car
a russian zill i think they called
with a uniform driver and an aide
and he came up the steps with uh
energy and
pumped my hand and was full of beans
full of uh
bon ami
um so i i
there was no problem of of
getting a rapport if you like uh he
wasn't standing off or or
being arrogant in any way so
it made things relatively easy to to
conduct the interviews what language did
you speak we spoke well we had a
woman interpreter
and she was translating english into
vietnamese and back
who is he
who is he who is he
well
it's it's a remarkable story um
if i can slightly digress here uh i
think
in in the modern world we live in
there's a great tendency to make people
either black or white or
positive or negative and you know very
little
shading in between and therefore
for
decades uh the vietnamese have been
regarded as communist paddies if you
like
the the people at the top end of it have
been regarded as as the
causes of
of all the problems that arose
over the years
personally i feel of course that people
are not all good and not all bad and
that they're a mix of things so to get
back to your point who is he
i think he was a man of exceptional
intelligence
uh who showed it at an early age
who did well in his school
um
in a sense got promoted to a better
school
and was bright
and highly intelligent throughout all
the time that he was growing up perhaps
a bit too bright in the sense that he
uh was highly nationalistic um and
anti-colonial anti-the french and that
was his chief motivation in the
beginning
um he was born in 1911.
so uh we're talking uh about the 30s uh
at the time when he was developing if
you like
i think that um like a lot of people in
those times in not only
in in the far east but all all over the
world in america in this country
people
looked at communism as a means of
perhaps sorting out some of the world's
problems and troubles
i think of course time has shown
that that was entirely wrong
the the system
is
proved to be unworkable
but people in those days didn't know
that um
and i think he he switched to communism
he read the writings of ho chi minh uh
it appealed to him
and i think he switched in
his allegiance to communist nationalism
if you like let me ask you before you go
any further
can you make the statement
and i can't remember if you made this
specifically in the book that he is the
most successful living general in the
world
yes i would think that that is possibly
true uh it's very hard to think of any
other
general um
certainly living today i mean perhaps
he's the most successful general of the
20th century and what did he do to
become the most successful
um
well
i i i'd like to go back to to pick up
the thread a little bit more about his
development because
he got
highly involved in this
communist theory
he was expelled from school for
subversive activities anti-french
anti-nationalist activities where'd he
live
um he was at school in in hanoi but he
lived in in the central part of vietnam
he was born in in the narrow neck
of vietnam
but um
he
began to write for
books and magazines
so much so that he he failed to qualify
as a lawyer he'd taken a degree at hanoi
university
in law but he needed a certificate to
practice and he didn't catch this
certificate so he became a teacher
having married and produced a daughter
and
he was still working actively uh in a
subversive sense
when uh the communist party was was
outlawed in in france um
and therefore in the french colony
he was told that he should
get away from hanoi he went north into
china
he met ho chi minh
and over a period of years he worked um
politically
but at one point in time ho chi minh
told him that he should be the man to
lead the military arm if you like of of
the vietnamese communist party
so uh
he
then
uh began to train
handfuls of of um
men
um
very basic
peasant type people from the northern
part of vietnam
so to develop the theme of how he became
to be the
perhaps the most successful general of
20th century
um out of this tiny beginning which he
started off with what he called an armed
propaganda brigade of 34 people
by the time he was finished he was the
commander-in-chief of 800 000
um
and
all
through the development of his military
life he
he learned he wasn't taught
in a conventional way he didn't attend a
military school
he had read a lot of
military history he was very interested
in the campaigns of napoleon
uh and so he and he used to teach also
uh military history so he was
somebody who who knew
uh if you like the basics but he was not
taught formally
but he built up from a rag tag outfit
as the months and years went by
from a purely guerrilla
force
through to a conventional
force
by the time the the french indochina war
was was well into its
first phase
uh he had gone from
smallish company-sized units to full
battalions to regiments even to
divisions
uh an armed by the chinese communists he
had
created an artillery division
to support the infantry divisions
so by the time the french really got
involved it was trying to
quell this subversion
they were faced with not just
a bunch of
of people leaping out of the jungle
throwing grenades firing disappearing
again they were faced with a proper
well-organized army
and this really was the pattern that he
developed
he never at any time uh had close
support aircraft for example as any
modern force would have
and really um
not until the very end did he have armor
in the sense of tanks
but he had all the other uh requisites
of of conventional warfare
um and of course uh his army grew and
grew
and had to be trained so they were
properly trained they had proper
training camps and so on and they were
turning out
officers and ncos and soldiers
let me interrupt before we go any
further to get some background on you
um you're a retired brigadier what does
that mean to those people who are not
military
um it's what you might call a middle
piece high rack
um
general a general yes the the bottom end
of the
of the general rank what year did you
retire
i retired in 1978. how long were you and
assumed the british army 32 years yeah
in those 32 years where did you serve
i served um in the middle east uh and in
europe
and that i didn't ever go to the far
east were you in a war
no no not in in the sense of a
conventional war um i was though
involved with the the british withdrawal
from empire if you like
uh in the sense that i was
involved with bomb disposal in cyprus
at the time when uh an organization
called aoka
was fighting against the british to get
us out of cyprus
and i also was involved in this in the
northern ireland conflict which is still
ongoing where do you live now i live in
bristol
in the west of england how many books
have you written nine and what about
mostly
well um
i find in life that you
sometimes unknowingly come to a fork in
the road and and decide to walk down it
i
became interested in the crusades
and when i was working in the ministry
of defence instead of
reading the newspaper going up an
evening paper coming down and hearing it
all again on tv i started to read books
about the crusade in particular the
knights hospital
because i was particularly
intrigued by the fact that here you had
the best soldiers of that time who were
actually monks who took all the vows
were highly disciplined
out of this i i
researched this for two years i then
spent two years writing this sort of
part time
and got it published so that the first
book was in fact a historical novel
about the crusades
i then wrote um
a sequence of four books a quartet of
books
taking one character as an officer in
the british army
parachute regiment
and taking him through the cyprus
campaign sue's intervention aiden
northern ireland and the last book was
the falklands interwoven with um
a sort of flash forward account of what
the third world
war might have been
uh timing wise that wasn't all that
clever because of course it's it's now
history but in a sense um
it was valid it still could be valid in
a slightly different way did the british
fight at all in vietnam
did the fact that you are british have
anything to do with why general zap
talked to
you i think
it probably did i think that a french or
an american
author
uh might have been considered to be
perhaps
very biased
or full of received ideas put it that
way um whereas a brit was a
uh somebody who had stood apart from
these conflicts and and might be blessed
by it has general zap ever written a
book
oh yes he's written several books um i
mean about his you know recounting his
uh activities
no he hasn't i mean he's written
several sort of communist um
theory books um setting out
uh regrettably in rather typically
communist jargon um particular lines of
thought after the gulf war general
schwarzkopf wrote a book about his
activities general zap has not done that
no do you have any idea why he hasn't
i think it's partly to do with the fact
that in
in any communist
regime
or they're slightly too faced about this
they talk about having no personality
cult
but of course you had stalin as a great
personality you had ho chi minh great
personality
uh almost deified um
but having said that i mean the theory
is that
they they rule they govern
in committee and therefore
yes a man may be a
a high-ranking person within the
committee but in theory he's got no more
power than anybody else and the
decisions are taken
by the group
so i think they have no um
tradition if you like of of writing
a personal
account
and certainly perhaps it wouldn't be
very acceptable for him to do so
um when ho chi minh died they they
sanctified him built this mausoleum um
created a focal point if you like for
for the regime and the men who were with
him uh particularly as time passed they
grew they sort of faded away i don't
think they want another uh
you know
a leader in in that sense did you go see
uh ho chi minh in the mausoleum yes what
was your reaction to that
um
i i went to hanoi with my younger son
um
we
went in a cyclo up to the
ho chi minh museum we had to get a pass
to get in had to hand in your camera
we then were taken by
a soldier to the head of the queue
because there was a great long queue of
vietnamese waiting to pay their respects
there
we went into the the mausoleum uh pink
marble walk up these long shallow stairs
and then you turn sharp right right
again you're into this room
uh which is guarded by
uniformed soldiers with fixed payments
standing in the corner and then the
queue of people just shuffles slowly
past
does a right angle another right angle
ho chi minh lying there
looking very yellow in a sort of yellow
light in a glass box
they have a slightly lower pathway for
the little kids to walk around so
they're not sort of training around the
adults
and
you know the whole thing was macabre
very
strange how long were you in hanoi
uh
about two and a half weeks i mean did
you see others besides general zach oh
it's a lot of people yes yeah
um they were very good in in that sense
they wheeled in
uh a lot of people uh ex sodas veterans
who had fought
both in the indochina war and in the
in the american vietnam war
and
um they seem to be
free to speak their mind and talk
very freely and and
i taped a lot of interviews and some of
them i used in the book um
i i think that they brought a sort of
flavor to it which was uh interesting in
that it
showed perhaps for the first time their
point of view about what was going on
were you ever concerned that they were
setting you up and just giving you
people that
would say exactly what they wanted them
to say um
this was a possibility of course i mean
i i i you you touched earlier on on was
the fact that i was british
instrumental in getting me there
um
i think the fact that i was an
established author was also partly
and the fact that i had been a soldier
was partly
probably he felt easier talking to
somebody who'd been a soldier than
to journalists
but um
i had to declare the fact that i'd been
in the british army i couldn't um
you know just pretend i was a person who
had no military background
so i think from their point of view they
must have been a bit suspicious of me um
you know why this guy want to come here
and and
do this
similarly i mean i was slightly
suspicious in the way you've just
suggested in in that um
maybe they weren't feeding me the right
stuff
but i did get the impression uh uh you
know from long
life of dealing with people
um that there wasn't uh dissimulation
going on that these
i mean
occasionally they trotted out the party
line
uh but then they've been living with the
party line were brainwashed and uh you
know automatically
but a lot of the time
these these people a lot of them quite
old men
uh were humorous and and direct and you
know i didn't feel that they were
setting it up how many americans did you
talk to
um
well actually out there none of course
no but in preparation for you in
preparation
um i spent um
one of my postings was in a nato
headquarters which had a lot of american
officers in it and uh over the years i
had
always been interested and i spoke to
them a lot and then of course the the
the key figure
uh was general westmonden
whom i interviewed when he came to
england
and
what did you learn from him anything new
well
i think um
what i learnt
really um
and it wasn't
if you like directly from him
but he underlined what i had
begun to to
feel and that was that
the the war was fought
from the american point of view for the
right motivation in the sense of
they felt that there was a tremendous
threat of communism creeping through the
world
they felt they had to do something about
it
but having taken that basic decision i
felt that they they got in
uh
deeper and deeper as time went on and
kept digging a bit deeper and deeper
um now from the military point of view
the the great mistake was that
the way to win the war was simply
to pile on the hot iron if you like
more soldiers more bombs more aircraft
and they did this despite the fact that
clearly it wasn't working
so i think one of the big military
uh
lesson if you like was you have to take
a deep breath and and say well this is
not the way you know got to do something
else and military
action is
a form of
somebody very famous once said
putting politics into a fort
so therefore if your military
action is not achieving the political
aim you have to stand back
the other big mistake politically
and who am i to say but i mean this is
my feeling
was that personalities
uh began to
drive the whole engine in other words
lyndon b johnson's personal involvement
became a matter of pride and he could
not back down and therefore the american
people would take along
on the basis of political
pride and the wish to stand again and
get reelected again and so on again
he didn't stand back and and
say is this the right thing to do
when did this book first hit the book
stores in the united states um in
january this year
any sense of whether or not it's selling
um
it's slightly disappointing from my
point of view because um
a great many servicemen
uh
were in vietnam
um and you know we're talking millions
and therefore
one would hope that there would be
several tens of thousand books sold but
it hasn't gone like that
i hope
it may do yet
did general westmoreland have anything
to say about general zap yes do you like
him did he know him he didn't know him
he admired him
he felt
not surprisingly that um this man must
be
an amazingly successful general to
achieve what he did
he did say that zapp
was very profligate with lives
um
and i think that this is a criticism
that's been said very often that [ __ ] had
no
uh concept of sanctity of human life
used to throw his soldiers in and let
them get churned up and so on
i think this is a matter of perception
first of all
it was not long after the korean war
um
in which the chinese had used the human
wave tactics
they were short on
equipment and technology therefore mass
attacks and and the whole concept of
submerging the enemy with with human
beings
um
was something which was
if you like accepted in the east so to a
certain extent and [ __ ] had
chinese military advisor perhaps the the
human wave tactic if you like
was um something that he
accepted to begin with there is another
factor too which is because of this lack
of of
of technology
men with a rifle
had had to balance things off the french
compared to
the viet minh um
you know were extremely well armed they
had an air
arm to support the ground forces
and the americans got involved of course
they were even
you know 10 times more
equipment oriented and technology
oriented in the french word
so in a sense the only thing [ __ ] could
do was to use manpower
since he couldn't
um
didn't have the technology so what i'm
saying is there's a sort of balance here
yes
he he had to accept casualties
but um
[Music]
this was a way of balancing off the
adverse technology
how tall is he
uh i would say he's about
five three
five or three and what kind of a life
does he live now were you in his
residence no i didn't go there
um i would say that uh obviously as as a
man who until very recently he was a
member of the politburo um
he he lives a comfortable life is he
revered in vietnam
i would say so yes yeah
near the end of the book you talk a lot
about general westmoreland you have a
chapter called disintegration
and you have some statistics in it i
want to read you say when american
servicemen finally quit vietnam they
left behind them
71 swimming pools
160 craft shops
90 service clubs 159 basketball courts
30 tennis courts 55 softball fields 85
volleyball fields two bowling alleys 357
libraries
and there were post exchange shops full
of jewelry perfumes lingerie booze
as someone put it it was like a walk
down fifth avenue why did you put that
in the book
that really was making the point that
it was war the american way
it really reflects back to what i said a
bit earlier on
i mean general westman's
point of view was that if he made life
as much as possible like life in the
united states the morale of the soldiers
would be high
my point is that
if you expect soldiers to go into the
jungle and live in appalling conditions
of heat and mosquitoes and
water and
torrential downpours and so on and live
a really hard life
is
actually worse for them in my view to
come back to be chop it out
at five o'clock in the evening when
they've done their their fire fight
and come back to an air-conditioned
canteen full of steaks and and uh you
know an iced coca-cola
um that's purely
my own
reaction that
they didn't actually use the large
numbers of soldiers
who were there
to the best
possible degree because such a lot of
them were involved in producing all
these
amenities and considering that soldiers
only did a year anyway
i think the right
mental attitude should have been
okay guys you're out here for one year
you're going to have one hell of a time
uh but this is how we're going to do it
and and and fight the war not to
uh there are other statistics there
which which are quite um compelling
um the number of troops actually
deployed in the front line at any given
time searching out the vietcong or the
the north vietnamese army was a tiny
proportion of the total
that's why i put it in there because i
think
it rather graphically spelt out
another
aspect of this
attitude of the way to fight the war he
asked you about this line
and there was another rule for when they
were in battle you're speaking about the
north vietnamese
do not mistreat prisoners something that
generally speaking they tried to abide
by
now when our american pows who are back
in country now hear that what do you
think their reaction will be to that
i hate my guts probably
but um
again it's it's a matter of perception
um if you
these people must have seen how the
vietnamese live i mean the vietnamese
uh is basically a peasant society living
on on absolute basic subsistence
now
for a soldier who has come from
a very affluent nation whether you're
talking about the french or the
americans or anybody else
who's taken prisoner by these people he
is going to be suddenly
expected to live at a in a way which he
has no conception of
and i think that's why i say it's a
matter of perception i think that
um
of course there were times when they
were harsh of course people had uh
terrible privations but i don't think it
was laid on especially i think that the
ordinary prisoner
in the central prison in hanoi probably
is no worse off than the ordinary
american gi who has the misfortune to be
there
from what you saw when you're and you've
been to hanoi before by the way
no i remember the first time i've been
what did you see there what were the
conditions of the people living there
um
well i i was really quite amazed because
uh one of the problems in vietnam of
course is a huge population explosion
uh at the time when we're talking about
you know in the 70s
talk about a population about 36 million
it's almost doubled now for both the
north and south yeah
and um
so one the first impression was that
hanoi is incredibly overcrowded
the second was that it didn't seem to
have had a lick of paint
or
you know
in any real
refurbishment
um for 40 years
it was rather like when i crossed over
into east germany when the wall came
down
you know you put the clock back 50 years
and exactly the same in hanoi
but i mean there were beggars around and
so on
there were people um
obviously living at a very low level
but um generally
um
the people themselves were in a better
shape than the city
do you give
and you have a chapter called the trail
do you give general zap credit for the
ho chi minh trail
um
essentially yes i think so i mean
going back to what i said earlier on the
the um
this business of committee decisions and
so on
uh
but in the sense that he was the driving
force throughout um you know the the um
the pivotal person yes i think so it was
a remarkable
achievement um
and done with very little to begin with
anyway
than
just human
power
i can't find it but i'm sure you
remember you you talked to a soldier who
fought in the war who told you about a
special
i mean that they used this on the trail
when they cooked their meals so you
couldn't see smoke is that as
an invention that this for instance
americans didn't know about
how did it work how'd that happen well
basically what they did was to when
they created an oven
uh which had um
a bit of a tunnel dug behind it
um
and the smoke
was blocked off at the front and was
pushed back if you like through this
tunnel which had a very small vent most
of the smoke carbon particles are
absorbed into the earth
and therefore they could cook and create
hot meals
without telltale
gushings of smoke going into the sky
you say u.s statistics show that in 1968
the year the greatest trail usage by the
way how where did the trail start and
how far did it go into the south
um it started off uh
in north vietnam and then came down
through lars into cambodia
and it started off as i explained in in
the beginning with just a small group of
people trailblazing if you like
the next development was to have
larger groups of people man packing
stuff
then gradually they
they created a
harder trail and they could use bicycles
they didn't ride the bicycles they were
heavy duty things which they adapted
but could carry quite a considerable
weight of stuff slung over the
crossbar
so it then became a trail of hundreds of
ant-like
people
pushing these bikes down this trail
and that grew became a metal road and
eventually they were running great
convoys of stuff i think they ended up
with three laterals about seven off
of takes into various parts of
of vietnam let me just read this u.s
statistics show that in 1968 the year of
greatest trail usage when an estimated
150 000 vietnamese
traversed the route
171 000 tons of bombs were dropped more
than one ton for every infiltrator
how many of those have they hit
well very few very few why
well um
i remember talking to an american airman
who had spent two tours in vietnam
trying f111s up and down
the trail
and
[Music]
he would explain to me how he would take
off and and fly cab rank if you like up
and down just inside the the border in
vietnam
uh and of course the the um
this amazing technology which the
americans had developed enabled them to
put
sensors down so sensors
along the trail which
relayed information
which was then
computerized collated and sent back to
the aircraft actually flying so that
when they're up there
going up and down flying cab rank taking
a sack every now and again off one of
these
big tanker aircraft flying above them to
keep themselves up in the air they would
suddenly get instructions to zap at a
particular target
and they would go ahead and do that but
then you have to remember the conditions
that you're actually trying to hit a
an arrow trail surrounded by jungle and
so on
um they did hit the trail often they hit
people but a lot of this this tonnage
was was scattered around
on either side of it
if they hadn't had the trail where they
won the war
um
that's a difficult one i i think also in
the book i say that
they need a relatively very small amount
of tonnage i think you're 60 ton a day
to keep
the
the viet cong and the infiltrated north
vietnamese army going
um
i think the answer to your question is
that without that trail they wouldn't
have got that 60 tons and they couldn't
have got it in by any other means so
probably no
no they wouldn't
but although
you know
the american air effort was enormous in
the fact that it killed uh or rather
that it it destroyed a large number of
vehicles uh in the latter days of the ho
chi minh trail
uh going back to this american friend of
mine who
i said to him
were you successful he said
peter we we
we killed off ten thousand trucks i said
that's a hell of a lot of trucks he said
no peter that's nothing they were a
hundred thousand truck
i think that to me
summed it up in a way i mean
that was the sort of proportion of
success
of all the books you've written where
would you put this in your
satisfaction level
um
oh pretty high i mean in in many ways by
by far the uh you know given me a
um
tremendous
amount of
interest and satisfaction
but fiction writing in other ways is a
different thing
um had general zap talked to any
body else since the war in
the same vein
i'm aware of no i've never seen any
evidence i mean he obviously has spoken
to
uh
so exodus strange enough i had a
um
in response to that book i had a letter
from a man called allison who was um
one of the people in the deer team which
is mentioned right at the beginning the
american group that went into
north vietnam to help their
ho chi minh
um
he he saw the book
and wrote and he in his letter he said
that he had actually
uh met dap
but um and and obviously he does
meet people
from time to time but i don't think
that facility has been offered of of
not only his
interviews with him but sort of the
backup if you like from
um from the military side out there i
went to their staff college in fact she
spent christmas day
which
will always be a memorable christmas day
as far as i'm concerned sitting in this
rather broken down barracks on the
outskirts of hanoi talking to a bunch of
vietnamese generals
eating bananas and drinking
green tea
what do they think about i mean are they
boastful about the victory
no i wouldn't say that
no it didn't strike me i mean
um
why did they think
they won both the nbn foo and the french
indochina war and the america i think
they felt they had the moral ascendancy
you point out several times in your book
that
public opinion played a very significant
role in their country and in our country
tell me
what's what was the difference
well um
i i think that
i suppose i've never really thought
about this but i think
the crucial difference was that public
opinion to them
was a positive factor and in america it
was a negative factor
and that
maybe was the real crucial thing in the
whole
episode
what i mean by that is that
basically there are simple peasant
people
they were brought up in a confusion
ethic of obedience
obedience to older people just slightly
digress here when i was leaving hanoi
they had a little sort of
celebration lunch
um
to which i was invited with my son and
they produced some
nice food and some beer and so on
actually they asked me to buy the beer
but that's all right
um
but i stood up there i was asked to say
something at the end of it and i stood
up and said i am the oldest man
sitting here
and it had an electric effect they have
this uh if you like this
reverence for older people um
i say i'm i'm digressing but it was
exactly the right thing to say that you
can heard a pin drop they were not just
listening to some foreigner they were
listening to an old man
now
going back to my theory because they
have this confusion idea of of um
of respect for order and uh and
obedience generally it was much easier
to persuade these simple people that
they were fighting
a righteous cause i think
the impression i have is that
there was very little doubting in their
mind that they were doing the right
thing that the french were interlopers
and so the americans had to get them out
now on the contrary side you have the
media you have a highly sophisticated
population
uh much more difficult to convince and
perhaps without that underlying moral
uh
tone which which this still exists in in
some of these other places
was general zap
a communist first
or a nationalist first
i i really i think only he could tell
you that i think that um the impression
is certainly that it was a development
uh what would be very interesting of
course would be to
be able to
to talk really talk and get a true
answer as to what he feels about
communism now
uh in in that it has um ceased to be
tenable as a as a political theory and
everywhere except in
turn in vietnam to some degree although
the barriers are coming down and they're
beginning to get capitalists and outlook
normally but north korea is about the
most stringent communist country left
in the world that's the only one and
you you um i mean even cuba now is is is
not what it was and that's
so that um
you you you seem to um
he must surely understand that uh that a
lot of what he put his faith in
you know it was a shimmer i feel like it
was
a fantasy again the year that you
interviewed him was 1990.
were there any questions he wouldn't
answer
um
yes but i don't think in in the sense
that you mean you know that that that he
shied away because of
um
some political overtone um it could have
been difficult to judge that
particularly you know you're not talking
directly in the same language and it's
all coming through an interpreter a bit
difficult i mean the things that she
shied away at
um
when he was talking about the air
defense of hanoi and i said to him
he said
we we had a
way of beating the the um
the bombers and i said what was that and
he said i i don't want to talk about it
you know it was he was in full speed
about something else
in fact what he was talking about was
that they would
send off one of these surface-to-air
missiles
which would then attract all the
electronic
gadgetry flying in the american air
formations
but they would follow it up on the same
beam if you like
uh a few second days with the second one
and the it was it was a subterfuge it
drew away the fire and all the
electronic
um
missiles and so on and the second one
would hit the target but that's what he
was talking about he didn't want to
answer it because it perhaps was a bit
of detail he didn't want to get involved
did the north vietnamese or the
vietnamese now did they record your
interview with him
no i recorded part of it my son
we borrowed or hired a video camera from
them
and my son recorded part of it but it
wasn't officially recorded now and out
of the interviews that you did what
would you say were the most important
things you learned and did any of it
surprise you
i don't know
if you're talking about the [ __ ]
interviews particularly are you right
yes um
no i mean i i did get
the feeling that um
he was repeating a lot of what he had
thought for a long time if you see what
i mean it was difficult to
to break into his uh
his train of thought
um
did he give long answers
yes
he tends to be very verbose
and of course this makes
life difficult when it's being
translated anyway because a poor
interpreter
is going
crazy trying to keep up and so on so
there were difficulties in this
um i
i think um
i can't sort of think of any particular
thing that struck me being very
surprising but
some of the interviews with some of the
veterans
were quite surprising i mean like for
example one of them says
i said to him did you have malaria and
he looked at me astonished and said yes
of course everybody had my life one
hundred percent we had one air
i said what did you do about it he said
nothing
you know i mean now this again is part
of that attitude isn't it if you see
what i mean
the relatively soft west
in contrast to this
hard
basic peasant eastern
attitude
i said but you must have been very ill
oh you you will you had to lie down for
three days and you got up and got on
with
now that i think that was surprising to
me you know
not much time and a lot to cover just i
want to get if i can so
brief questions and maybe some brief
answers so we can see what's in the book
yeah caisson what role the battle of
caisson what role did that play in the
war
um it played
a bigger role of course in the american
consciousness than it did in the
vietnamese um
in a sense uh it was another day in
being foo and
from lyndon b johnson downwards
everybody was keyed up to the fact that
there must not be another dnb in food
what does that mean for people who've
never heard of dna right well uh dn bin
foo was the coup de gras if you like of
of the indo-china war
yeah managed to
lay siege to a french
fortress which had been built to stride
the road into laos
um he managed to produce 55 000 soldiers
plus a large number of guns and all the
ammunition that was needed for these
guns
and surround this place uh
and it was one of the classic battles of
history he eventually
uh ground them down
and eliminated
the french garrison at dmv and foo which
consisted mostly of paratroopers and
legionnaires a cream of the french army
for the french it was a traumatic defeat
uh what year shattering 1954.
uh was that it for the french then yeah
i mean it just happened but the day he
took december of may
1954 a conference opened
in geneva to discuss amongst other
things the future of
indochina
the french
had the ground cut away from
they had no way they could go back and
they just pulled out
uh i hate to jump around but there's a
lot of i'll come back to this uh your
son you keep mentioning uh how old is he
and what does he do he's a portrait
painter um
he's 33 years old
and how much did he have to do with
helping you on the book or not at all
except well
uh tremendous moral support he's a great
chap
full of humor
vietnamese loved him all laughing all
the time and so on he was tremendous
from that point of view he took notes
for me but in the actual writing no did
you go anywhere else in vietnam
um
no no i didn't have you sent a copy of
this book to general zap yes i have
any reaction no
we talked before where the cameras came
on about the name
g-i-a-p
what is the correct way to pronounce it
and
how do you pronounce it and how do
americans pronounce it i always used to
say vo nagoya and gear but they say von
wins up
so it's like a z yes like a t yeah
the tet offensive yes what is your view
of that emp what impact did did the
americans win the tet
offensive that in 1968 yes military yes
yes they did i mean uh there's no
question about it and general westman is
absolutely
clear that the the casualties inflicted
on on the viet cong
uh were enormous and there's no doubt of
this um
one vietnamese general called chamber
and char who says uh who wrote later
that um
they were completely decomated
that's a wrong word it means to kill off
one tenth there was much more than a
tenth that went um
they they never really recovered from
that until
uh
[ __ ] was in a position to to launch a
full-fledged military assault
um so military
yes uh no question about it
psychologically
it was almost a death knell
what do you think general zapp's real
talent is
i i would say uh energy
uh he must have been a man of enormous
uh
determination energy and his strategies
he was a strategist um
he was an all-round uh very clever
military man i mean
logistically
um
as i've just touched on this business
dmv and foo
the problems of shifting these tonnages
with guys pushing bicycles and man
packing stuff were absolutely gigantic
to actually inspire people to do this
must have been a tremendous achievement
you contrasted the first of all you said
the general westmoreland and general zap
read the same military strategists klaus
woods and others
yes
how did you know that did you ask them
both
yes
did did either
did that have any impact on them
um in what sense i mean in other words
they're both generals they both studied
the same military strategist in history
yes
uh they obviously came out looking at it
a little differently all right yes i i
was very surprised to hear general
westman tell me that he had not studied
the end of china war
because
he never did
apparently not um i liked him i admired
him um you know i don't want to say
anything
is hurtful to him but it did surprise me
that he had not
studied this because after all he was
fighting the same people in the same
general
and they had fought the french for nine
years so
i asked him actually if they had studied
it at fort leavenworth or at the war
college and that happened
so
i think perhaps that was a mistake
in your opinion which american president
got us in
deep in vietnam oh lyndon johnson i
think
i mean kennedy uh
started with eisenhower and the domino
theory kennedy picked up that baton and
ran with it uh lyndon b johnson was was
committed already when he got there but
as i said right at the beginning
perhaps
standoff and a bit of thought
and taking advice of people you see a
long for a long time
uh
it was thought that the vietnamese were
acting on behalf of a sort of proxy for
the chinese
history
teaches you that the vietnamese loath
the chinese always have done for a
thousand years
um it was very unlikely that they were
going to spill their blood in order to
hand the whole thing over to communist
china
after looking at the vietnam war what in
your opinion
are the lessons
it was a tragedy in in every sense um
for everybody involved for the
vietnamese for the french for the
americans um
appalling waste of life
and the money and resources that were
sunk in the whole thing
i think the the
the lessons are that
it is very easy to whip up sentiment the
media
uh
for want or something to say we'll we'll
pick up a ball and run with it
uh and the people because this is human
nature you sit there and you watch the
screen and you believe what you read and
what you're looking at and pick what you
read in the paper
in both cases you
you know the french and the americans
you had this um
tremendous
surge of of feeling that
you had a great enemy here that had to
be killed off
um
i believe that
well
you know the domino's theory has been
shown not to be correct that the common
nature has not fallen to the communists
i was in in kuala lumpur a month ago uh
a thriving uh
modern
country
modern city in a modern country there's
nothing communist about that they're
totally capitalists and
and love it
and yet that was part of the theory that
we were fighting to prevent
burma malaya and all those falling
together here's what the book looks like
our guest has been peter mcdonald
and this is the victor in vietnam the
book is zapp the general who headed up
the vietnam forces both at dmv and foo
and in the american involvement thank
you very much for joining us my pleasure
thank you
join us next week for book notes when
our guest will be joseph ellis professor
of history at mount holyoke college
he'll be here to discuss his recent
biography of our nation's second
president the book is titled
passionate sage the character and legacy
of john adams
that's book notes
next sunday night on c-span at 8 and 11
p.m eastern time
coming next on c-span a look at politics
in great britain
[Music]
c-span and its companion network c-span
2 are the cable television industries
networks for public affairs if you have
a comment